hello in this video i would like to explain
the caymans you have analysis in a simple
way first i come to the
question what is the caymans cluster
analysis and how does it work
then i will show you how
the cayman cluster analysis can easily
be calculated online
my  name is mathias and i am the
founder of goethe and here we go
so the first question you will surely ask yourself
is what is
the caymans cluster analysis the caymans
cluster analysis is one of the simplest
most common
methods for classifying the chimney of vegetables  do you have
your data points on a specified
number of clusters
so you have to know in advance how many
clusters you want to have but
more on
that later the initial situation is now to follow we
have a data set and
we would like to divide this data set into clusters
so we have our initial
data set  and we would now like to rasterize this data set, come
on  Let's get to the
question of how does the kevins cluster work?
This caymans class
analysis can be explained in five steps
. We will now go into more detail
on each of these individual steps. At the end of these five steps, we have
then clustered our initial data set.
Now let's start with the
first point  define the number of clusters
at the very beginning
we have to define the number of clusters that we want to have
that is the k in kate - so if we
learn this example you can already
see with the eyes that
we actually want to have three clusters
accordingly, in this example we use
sk equal to three, so we want to
have three clusters in the end,
in the second step, the cluster
center is determined randomly, the
initial clusters are determined
this usually happens randomly,
so we initially place
our three points in this space purely randomly  so
we have selected three clusters therefore
must  en we randomly position three cluster centers
each of the
android power plants now represents a
cluster so now we have defined the number
of clusters in the first step
and in the second step we have
randomly positioned the button centers in
the room in social and now we can go
to the third step  in the third
step we do the each point to the
clusters
so let's start with one
point now the distance from the
first point to each of the clusters is
measured
so if we have a point here
we measure the distance from this point
to each cluster  then the
point is assigned to the cluster which
is closest to it, so here it is right
that this point
is closest to the yellow cluster, so we need to
add this point to the yellow cluster, this
is now repeated for all other points
, so each point is assigned a
plaster
then all points are initially back in a
cluster  kinstruction again somehow
defines the number of clusters we want to save 3
then we have
now initially positioned the centro clusters in the room
and only in the third step have we assigned
all the points to a cluster in the
fourth step we now calculate the
mean value of the clusters so in the
end  we now have a lot of
green dots a lot of red dots
and a lot of yellow dots which represent our
class
we now calculate
the average of these
points we then use this average as the new cluster
center so the average of each cluster is
calculated these are
averages  now the new trust center
wales so the clusters android will be moved to the
center points class
so we come to the next
step in the fifth step the
points are assigned to the new cluster since the center can
now be placed at another
point the cluster is assigned to each point again
which is
next to him  sten is
so if we look to the left here that was
our initial situation,
but we have moved the cluster center
accordingly, there are also other
distances between the points and the
cluster center and if we now
assign each point to the kaarster
which is closest to it then
we get the result here on the
right side
so now all five steps are actually
through and there is a
last loop
so we repeat step four and
five now step 4 and 5 is
repeated until I
no longer change the first division as a supervisor step
4 and 5 now again, first the
average value of each cluster is calculated
, then the cluster
android is moved to the center and
then all points are
assigned to the new classes again,
if the clusters in an
integration no longer change, the
procedure
is over  if that's the previous step
now let's do a sc  hritt further and we
have the clarity again have assigned new ones
to this
loop none of these points will change in the next loop
so
the cluster procedure is over at this point
and we have found our cluster
now of course the big question is always
which initials which  testers are
used a big disadvantage of the canes
method is that the result depends very much
on which initial clusters
are used, so we said
we simply set the class of the centers
initially randomly
, but now it can be depending on where
you put these cluster
centers  different end results
come out to
take this fact into account
, the whole procedure is
carried out several times
in each of the calculations then
different randomly selected
starting ends are
used then the guest cluster is
used which averages the smallest sum
of distances between the
clusters  elpunkt and all the other
types in the case of datatec, for example, the entire
cluster procedure is repeated ten times and
at the end the best
patch is used and the user is presented with the
second big question, of course, what is
the optimal number of clusters,
it becomes clear with each new one  cluster the
summed distance in the clusters gets
smaller and smaller
so let's take a look at this picture
here we just chose two
clusters if we now go from two clusters
to three clusters we can of
course map the data points better
and especially the summed
distance  from each point to the cluster
center is of course
smaller in this case than in this case, so with
each additional cluster that we
add, the distance becomes
smaller and smaller in
the end if we then have the same number of
cluster points this
distance is of course 0
but this  nothing is done
now the big question is how many cluster
s
If you want to use the so-called l method, you can use the so-called l
method again with each
additional cluster with the summed
distance between the points the cluster
center becomes smaller and smaller,
however, there is a fixed number from which
each additional cluster in the summed
distance is only slightly smaller than
this point  used as the number of
clusters why do we look at that here
so if we jump from cluster number 1
to class s we see that we are
making a big jump so
summed up the distance is greatly
reduced
just as from class 1 2223 but
if we then  jumping from the kerstan 234
we see that the distance is
no longer reduced as much as
in the arrow between two and three,
so class
number 3 is used in this case, so this
method is also called the elbow method because
otherwise you would
get your elbows out  searches and
then uses this as the clearest number so and
now möch  te i will show you again
we can calculate the gaming cluster analysis directly
online with data
for this please go to date up
de sixt also the statistics calculator
and since we want to do a clear analysis
clique operators also cluster
analysis up here you can do your
own  Insert data for this clique
first on table teachers and
then simply copy his actions here
I am now using a format the example
so we want to use this one class higher
and we want to use a campions cluster
analysis say we want to form
a cluster for the data
income  and age so bmw has according to
income and age from here we
have to work out how many clusters we
want to have we will just choose the number
three so that we
want to have character and now calculated and started
the cluster analysis we see
our three testers 123  with the
respective class patients if you
scroll down here  we see
the elbow method
in this case we can see that
the number of
two clusters would probably actually
be perfect because we have a large
drop here and from then on we only have a
small one at but let's
first look at the number with three clusters
the  results to hang
here we see how many
cases have been individually assigned to clusters
and here we then see our faithful
telegram
here we see that we have
clusters here here a fun and
another cluster up here
at the end you can see
all the points again  listed and which
cluster the points were assigned to,
but as I said, it actually came out
with the elbow method that we
best choose two clusters, so
we will choose the number of classes with 2 and
if you now
look at faithful diagrams you can also see it
up here  a cluster and see the
second cluster below and here again the division of
the egg  individual points for the
clusters so i hope you liked the video
if you liked it
i would be happy about a dress and
we will definitely see you again soon ciao